the undead appear in most cultures and
folklore and Norse mythology is no
different the drow gear were once Viking
warriors who had sworn an oath and oaths
so strong that it could not be broken
even through death their corpses are
reanimated upon death but unlike regular
zombies they do not roam the earth
freely they remain by their grave often
garden the treasures that were buried
with them they can be found on both land
and sea with the corpses of those who
drowned rising from their watery graves
these that are gear are described as
being made entirely from seaweed and
some even believe that they took the
form of a headless fisherman sailing a
boat made from a living corpse the drow
gear are in no way immortal they were
reanimated as a rotting corpse and their
body continued to rot and decay it is
said that the foul smell of a drug is
rotting corpse can be snot from miles
away with nearby animals often being
driven insane by these mythical
creatures the drought gear possessed all
of the abilities they had in their
previous life with a host of new ones
including superhuman strength and the
ability to grow to giant proportions
when it came to dealing with those who
were brave enough to enter their domain
the Draghi is preferred method of
dispatching their victims was by
crushing them they were known to eat the
flesh and drink the blood of those they
had killed both human and animal the
drought gear were not inherently evil
similar to a ghost
they often linger because they have
unfinished business or because they
refuse to pass on when they are
reanimated they possess only a fraction
of their previous intelligence and their
only real purpose is to protect the
treasure that was buried with them this
could explain their disregard for the
life of humans and animals and even
their savage behavior killing a drug ear
is no easy task as they were often known
to reanimate themselves after being
defeated removing their head burn in
their body and throwing the ashes into
the sea or some of the ways that one
would ensure at our gear would stay dead
the word precautions taken to ensure
that the dead did not become that our
gear these included tying their big toes
together and driving needles through
their feet to keep them from rising from
the grave and walking the through our
gear can be found in a host of video
games including Skyrim Witcher and even
world of warcraft
you will often see them in caves or
catacombs garden treasure so next time
you come across a chest filled to the
rim with riches think again because you
may be the next victim of a drug year if
you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
[Music]